okay so I want to thank professor cop
for the introduction it's a great honor
to be introduced by you may be something
that will be said about me the next time
I give a talk and you mentioned the ITA
workshop so I should tell people that
when we started the workshop it's
actually almost ten years ago we wanted
to get credibility for this workshop and
at that time of course it didn't exist
and we said that the best way we can get
credibility is to have our first keynote
speaker bit off s okok so I think if
we'd succeeded somehow then I think a
lot of it is thanks to the initial push
that you gave us so thank you for that
as well okay so yes so I'm going to talk
about the good touring publicity
estimation formula but of course in
order to get you to come here I had to
rephrase it in terms of what Alastor
codes and academy award-winning movie
because it wants some very small award
and it's are based on what a lot of
people did including our work that was
done by many of my students that are
listed here and they all worked on
different aspect of probability
estimation and a lot of them touch on on
this work and I particularly want to
mention another tutor surah she is here
someplace duta where are you right there
who has done like amazing work both on
this and other topics and has helped a
lot with the gym yeah with this with
this presentation okay so okay so I want
to start with but a spoiler alert so no
don't worry it's not that I'm going to
tell you what's going to happen in the
movie that's not the spoiler alert
because the movie actually starts with
the end so obviously they think that
there are more important things then how
it ends it's actually much broader than
this it's that I think that after you
hear this talk you may be able to put
not just this movie but maybe a lot of
things that you are not able to predict
before so watch out a little bit so so
speaking of prediction suppose that you
want to go on a safari and you want to
estimate the distribution of animals
that you're going to see so a very
natural thing to do is to google it and
look at some images and stuff and for
example you see this one and based on
what you see you want to estimate the
type of any of the animals that you'll
see in the proportions and so on so here
we see we see one giraffe two elephants
and three zebras we see six animals all
together and so what probability will be
assigned so one reasonable thing to do
is what's called empirical frequency so
we've seen six animals altogether which
one giraffes and elephants and so on so
we'll give them the corresponding
probabilities 16 one-third and one-half
okay and of course a natural question to
ask is is this estimation good is there
any problem and what do people think the
yes right this is problem that is that
you may not come back alive from your
trip so so to address this poem this
poem actually is not new like two people
in Africa and so on I found that the
French were preoccupied with a long time
ago in around 1800 in the early eighteen
hundreds they were concerned with the
probability to the Sun may not rise
because they saw that it will rose rose
rose rose but they're pretty smart so
they said one day
I seemly the probability that the Sun
will not rise and in particular plus
came with an estimator said that in
order to avoid giving zero probability
to things that might happen let's modify
things a little bit and let's add one to
the number of times you see every single
thing so including two things you have
not seen so the Sun rose n times we'll
pretend that he throws n plus 1 times it
didn't rise 0 times we'll pretend it
enjoys once ok so together the you need
to normalize of course sound r n+ to our
possibilities and the probability that
will rise is n plus 1 over n plus 2 and
the probability that will not rise is 1
over n plus 2 and and this actually is a
pretty good estimator the only the only
small mistake that Laplace need is in
this calculation is that he estimated
the age of the universe by 5000 years
but except for that part in English is
right on it so um ok so if we go back to
the Safari what will they do so we'll
say we saw one giraffe will pretend that
we saw two will pretend that we saw
three elephants three zebras in one new
so when you add those number again
you'll get to 10 so the public of
giraffes is going to be one fifth and so
on and now probability of new is going
to be one tenth so at least you are
prepared to seeing something you have
not seen ok and though many you don't
have to add one and one has a lot of
nice features if you assume that you
have a dis uniform distribution over
your parameters your uniform prior then
that will give you the posterior will
also minimize some important distances
if you assume that so it has some nice
features but people add other constants
depending on what they want to do ok and
the question is whether this estimator
is all is good ok so let's look at
slightly more modern application DNA
suppose that you try to find the
distribution of DNA sequences so I know
they are very smart people here and they
they already realize it's a very stupid
question because it's not that there's
one DNA sequence that appears many times
everyone is a different DNA sequence but
hopefully that's something that will
come out of our experiment so you take a
very large number of samples
okay and of course you'll see that all
of them are different all DNA sequences
that you see are different so if you try
to apply the Laplace estimate then each
DNA sequence you observe you observed
one so you pretended to soy twice okay
and you you'll give a count of one okay
so the total count is going to be 2 n
plus 1 okay and each sequence that was
observable give it probably 2 over 2 n
plus 1 each new gear 1 over 2n plus 1
and so is there a problem with this
estimate of course there is because you
know that if you're going to look at the
next person then the probability you'll
see something new is going to be close
to one but according to this calculation
the probability of seeing something new
is 1 over 12 plus 1 which is almost zero
it's the opposite and the probability
that you'll see something you've seen
before according to this calculation is
this level 2 times n 2n it's close to
one the opposite of what you would like
to see okay so so so this the laplace
estimator works well when you have a
small number of items small alphabet if
you want and you have many samples then
it works well but if you have a very
large alphabet it does not work well as
we saw here and this is not you can
instead of adding 1 to all of them you
can add one to each one that you have
not seen that will have a different kind
of problem but none of these works okay
so that is the problem that Gooden are
touring are faced during World War Two
and I just want to give you a little bit
of the work of the background world war
two lasted six years here it's shown one
stage of the war the this is these are
the x axis power powers the pretty large
and growing and these are they I'm sorry
the Allied forces and small and
shrinking and shrinking okay and so what
happened was that the Americans and the
Canadians and so on try to help protect
whatever if Europe was let was our
remain and they sent convoys to with
both military and strategic supplied
that was of course resulted in what's
called the bathroom the Atlantic raged
in those years and in in this in this
battle the Allied forces lost thirty
thousand sailors 100 civics and five
warships and and 3500 merchant vessels
so you figure it's about like three a
day vessels that were law so it was a
big it was a big issue and the culprit
behind behind us with the u-boats which
are German abbreviation for undersea
votes and there were about a thousand of
them each of them with 15 torpedoes and
actually Churchill said that the only
thing that really scared him during the
world was the u-boat pill okay and but
so this was actually pretty pretty bad
at some ways very green but luckily
there was a sliver of hope of hope so in
other words the answer was there
everyone could hear it was all over the
air waves but it was they just had to
decipher and deal with this 159 million
million million combinations and so on
okay so in order to do that or so of
course they what he's talking about is
the Enigma machine shown here which was
developed during World War one and was
continually used commercially but the
use was picked picked in during World
War two had three to six rotors and each
of them corresponds to a permutation
code and every letter that you type
would change the permutation code so
it's not like you have the same
permutation consisting of a long message
every single letter did you type had a
different permutation code so order to
solve it they would have to figure out
the setting of the machine like what's
the original setting and try all
possible combinations so that's what
he's talking about and to solve that of
the British constructed the government
and code and cypher school in Bletchley
Park it was about 50,000 miles northeast
of London and was chosen the location
was chosen why because it was on the it
was on the train line between oxford and
cambridge and they needed people to come
from both places so instead of ten men
that he was talking about looking at at
this pump they had more like 10,000 men
and women trying to solve the code and
try different combinations to see what
they could do and and of course this was
not enough so they actually also
invented before built the first computer
it's called Colossus or if you watch the
movie you'll see it's called Christopher
for some reason and was completed in
1943 ok so in other words even with the
computer they didn't have enough
computing power and uh so but at some
point they had according to the movie a
breakthrough ok so so they had to so the
idea was that if they could figure out
like for each commanded to boot
commander the modes are more likely to
to say then they could look for those
words in the message and then they could
speed up the search they also be the
same same thing for password and so so
that's where so that's what good and
touring we're involved with the go
touring estimation from Allah so Alan
Turing basically graduated from
Cambridge anyhow do found it defined and
found the first results on computable
numbers it showed that the halting
problem was on the side of all these
were about thirty six then went to
Princeton's and got his PhD with Alonzo
Church and 39 I he was at Berkeley
working on this and I J good he got he
studied the Cambridge they are got his
PhD with gh auditing and then in 1941
joined Bletchley Park is a very prolific
author we were just saying he wrote over
3 million words network is known for so
what is the good touring estimator so
the so in order to to look at empirical
frequency in Laplace we needed just a
couple of animals in order to do the
good touring estimator we need more like
a whole zoo ok and so imagine that you
see what you see now 10 and one Rhino
you see two elephants two lines two
cheetahs in two jackals and three zebras
hippos and Brazil's okay so empirical
frequency
we'll give any each animal probability
which is proportional to the number of
times that it was seen so giraffe was
seen once you'll give a number that's
proportional to 1 elephant seen twice
and numbered probability
disproportionately to you have to add
them up all together here you've seen 19
animals so the normalize by 19 so that's
empirical frequency and Laplace would
add one would give a number that's
proportional to this number of plus one
number position to two and three and now
we need to normalize by 29 and what good
interring did was something which is
actually quite odd they started with
Laplace they took Laplace they added one
and then so it's two and three and then
what they did was they multiplied by the
number of animals that appeared once
more than what you're looking at and
divide by the number of animals that
appear the same number of times so for
example here there are 22 animals that
appeared once two species the 48 appear
twice and three that appeared three
times so if you want to calculate the
probability of giraffes you'll take the
number two okay and here too and you
multiply it by 4 over 2 and you'll get
four and for elephant you take three
because two plus one and then you
multiply by three how many appeared once
more and divide by four actually and 225
and now you need to normalize it when
you do the calculation it's easy to see
that the normalization and the
normalization factor is actually exactly
the same as the number of animals so
here it's going to be 19 okay right so
that's the estimator and is there a
problem with this estimator of course
there is because if you look at zebras
for example then you take three plus one
is four but now we need to multiply by
the number of animals that appeared [ __ ]
with it appeared four times which is
zero so get some problem but that's a
problem only for small-minded people
like us they had smoothing in other ways
of doing it so it becomes smoothing and
there's a whole family of estimators
some people say a lot a whole religion
of estimator and so on okay so so some
observations is that the good touring
estimator is surprising and complex it's
surprising because why would you care if
you want to estimate the public
and anymore why would you care about
things other things and let alone other
things that appeared once more more than
what you're looking at and also why they
all these complicated smoothing methods
but in fact it works well for especially
infrequent elements and so it's a very
popular in use in speech recognition
machine translation data mining all the
applications that have things that
happen with small probability typically
use that it's also sub optimal for
frequent elements so sometimes people
use some combination of these two
estimators will shew imaginably electron
and and like I said there's lots of
complications about this and our papers
like good touring frequency estimation
without tears and so on and good itself
actually himself published the work
after the war in 1953 just a year before
touring died and it's this is his paper
and in his paper he mentions that Alan
Turing suggested to him and this formula
along with an intuitive explanation
fortunately it doesn't write what is
what the intuitive explanation is and of
course a lot of people have tried to
figure it out including us maybe we will
maybe one of the explanations correct
okay so so let's try to see what is the
issue when trying to estimate other
small probabilities so so the so the
basic question that good terrain as the
critic touring estimator brings up is
why should you change the proportion of
things you have seen okay so for example
suppose you see an element that appear
ten percent of these samples 10 out of
100 samples who who are we to say that
it should have appeared more times who
are we to say it should appeared less
times it's like so your student you get
a grade in the examined the professor
says okay I see you got 90 but actually
think we should change it now to 80 you
know why why why increase why decrease
okay and and and let's even say that you
say okay I maybe they should why should
they see why should look at other
elements i look at the probability of
giraffes why should i care about the
number of times other animals appears
for example again element ten percent of
the time why should I care if so this is
the ten percent why should I care if
there's only one other in the world that
is ninety percent or I have three other
animals that come back together combined
ninety percent why should it even make a
difference kind of like odd okay so um
so it's it's definitely counterintuitive
some people say it's inconceivable and
reasonable and my hope or my goal and
then if I'll chain it is to tell you
that not just not is not inconceivable
but maybe it's somewhat in retrospect it
should be obvious so maybe it's like
inconceivably obvious so that's that's
our goal so um okay so what is so what
I'll do is I'll give you what I think
would so like we've been working on this
for some time so we've developed some
some ideas why we think it works so I'll
explain to you what we think if you like
those things and here is the most basic
one so what did what is the basic
question so you've seen n samples and
some element pay t times okay and the
question is should you sometimes modify
to your right should you should be
hubris should we have the hubris to say
no it that's what is wrong I should
modify and if if you do then how should
you modify to do increase should
increase it or decrease it okay should
you say that the element was
undersampled or oversampled how would
you decide okay and of course once you
do it of course it's engineers we would
care by how much so we know what the
right answer should be okay so um so
let's look at empirical frequency in the
class so again n samples and element 2
30 times empirical frequency just says
take T over N okay so it says don't
change is there a problem with this yes
there are few problems one of them is we
saw is that you won't give any problem
to things they have not seen that that
is an issue in many applications we give
we give to but if imagine your google
and someone you know right and every
word that you say just assumes that you
know that they know what it is they
don't allow for the possibility that
it's something that they have not seen
so that's an issue but even even if
without us even without
and sensible if you use empirical
frequency then you will not approximate
the distribution as well as you as you
can that requires some work but you can
show that so so that's that's so that's
empirical frequencies don't change and
has some problems ok let's look at
Laplace so Laplace we said you take if
an element to purity times you add one
and if you have K symbols so let's say
let's assume the alphabet size is k then
you'll add one to each so you'll have n
plus K in the denominator ok and so it
does change p over n okay to change to t
plus 1 over n plus K and the question is
does not plus play God does Laplace
decide that he knows what was
underestimated and what was
overestimated it estimated so let's see
what it does so which direction does
Laplace change the probability of an
element so it will increase if T if T
plus 1 okay the number of times P plus 1
over n plus K that's the numerator the
denominator if you have K different
symbols is bigger than Tyrion in other
words if TN plus n is bigger than TN
plus DK & t n cancels in other words if
T is less than n over K so if T that if
an element appeared and of that you took
and samples and that K different symbols
k different animals so this is the
average number of time that an animal
appears so if an animal appeared less
than the average Laplace says no it was
under sample I'm going to increase if it
appeared more than the average then says
it was over sample I should decrease it
so um okay so that's what we say here
okay so this is what laplace says and
and of course the question is can we do
any better is there anything else we can
do okay and it's quite clear that if
there's something else you can do then
you have to look at other things I'm not
saying it will work but if there's
something that would work because this
is all the information you have then you
have to see what up this is all the
information if you have if you don't
look at what other things happen so if
you want to do anything more than that
you should look at what how many times
other things that appeared okay so the
question is so so can we do better and
necessarily from what to do whether we
would have to look at other symbols so
we want to infer
the problem the probability from the
occurrences of other symbols and my
question to you is can you think of why
you would want to use that and at this
point I'm not asking for a formula I'm
just trying to ask just maybe convince
me that I should look at other things
even though I'm only looking the
probability of giraffe do our perp you
10 times I should look at what other
animals appeared and maybe you can also
tell me if I should increase or decrease
that's my goal I want it at least on an
intuitive level we should be understand
be able to understand this and your
thoughts
that's two two guys huh and and I'm sure
for thinking about Germans and British
then show the logic applies maybe that's
how they started with the idea okay so
okay so so let me give you a few hints
and then see if we if we can do can we
can think so um so we have a
distribution and like we said this works
for things that appear in frequently if
you only have two elements if you flip a
coin probably forty percent sixty
percent you don't want to use empirical
frequent you won't want to use our go
touring estimation you can you can do
quite well so this works for things that
you have a distribution over many many
different things each appearing small
probability and so on okay so so and the
number of times that a single X appear
is going to be by normally distributed
but we can if the number is large enough
maybe we can approximate it with some
Gaussian with mean n times P X and is
the number of samples e 2 px is the
probability of the element so it's kind
of a Gaussian distribution so that's a
start so our goal is to infer PX from
this from from the number of times that
period which is distributed gouge okay
now we're trying to get some intuition
so so one question you would ask is
maybe we can find maybe we cannot think
of giraffes in Safari and so on but
maybe you can think of something more
mundane that has a Gaussian distribution
something happens more commonly that
maybe will give us some intuition can we
think of something that's the serrated
Gaussian so I think if you're touring
you probably say yes I can think of a
lot of things probably everything in
life is Gaussian right and because
anything that's a summer fur that's the
result of many different factors in some
sense will be Gaussian so so almost
everything is Gaussian so let's look for
example at a tight okay so someone's
height is a function of their ethnicity
and their gender and the father's height
and mothers height and age and food
quality and food quantity and a lot of
other things and all of them are
somewhat independent and so once you add
them up you'll get a Gaussian
distribution let's say off the heights
ok so it's maybe it's the stupid
Gaussian or maybe if you want you can
say Gaussian mixture
and so on but something like that so the
question is um so so so we can think we
can see that the height of the person is
very closely related to the number of
time a symbol appears because the
similar period Gaussian number of times
in a person's height is also distributed
devotion okay so this is a big big hint
should we look at other things when you
try to estimate the actual so we observe
and anyone an element to be x times we
try to estimate the probability should
we how should we just divide by n the
number of times or should we do anything
else do we assume ins do we use other
clues to estimate to see if something
happen less than than than the actual
probability or more was undersampled or
over sample in this case is the person
shorter than there should be or taller
than this should be okay okay so let's
let's get Tin Tin to help us so much
knees his team team Tom what do people
think stint in tom it's hard to say
right but let's make it easier for us
his stint in total short i would say
tint in his short is shorter than like
the mean of the distribution so tinting
comes from some distribution but he was
under sampled you should the actual
distribution should be higher okay now
in this put in this case you can say
this is already laplace tells us this
because as you can look at the average
and this thinking is less than the
average so you can see that his you know
he is relatively short to the
distribution but you can think of a
distribution that's more complex than
this that maybe has maybe it's a mixture
of two gaussians and maybe these two
gaussians just to simplify for yourself
a far apart so now if i see the tinting
lies on this part of the distribution
then even though he might be he might be
larger than the mean because i have two
distributions here's two gaussians
tintin was on the short side of this
distribution he's taller than the mean i
still say that he shorted compared to
his to the distribution that generated
him because his problem was more general
most much more likely to be generated by
this Gaussian so what I need to do is a
need to look at people close to me and
ice need to see if the derivative going
up or going down if the derivative is
going up then I was undersampled if the
derivative is going down I was under if
the is going down then I was oversampled
that clear so this is the intuition of
good toy that's what we believe so
beyond that so beyond that we need to
see if we once we if we buy this we need
to calculate the how to exactly change
the probabilities okay so that requires
actually some work so um so what I want
to do next is talk about some
experiments that that that we you can do
we have done and some are in
mathematical nutrition is supposed to
hear the basic intuition and then some
proofs and I think watching counter so
experience so um so so if you want to
see how well if your existing
experiences to see so here here here
will show you a couple of experiments so
take addictive submission with a
parameter 1 so the probability is 1 over
I and I going from 1 up to 100 and then
you normalize and you take 1,000 trials
and then what you do is you take
empirical frequency and you try to see
what is the l1 distance between the
actual distribution and you estimate and
then you take Laplace so this is
empirical frequency and you take Laplace
you get this curve and you take with our
go touring you get this curve so you can
see for example it is with 100 so this
is a distribution of a 100 elements and
if you take 100 samples so it's
relatively small because it's comparable
to the size of the distribution on
average you see available once so take
100 you see that the probability goes
down from let's say what point 6 let's
say 2.45 something that so it's a it's a
significant increase I'm sorry l1
distance okay and if you are if you are
if you now change the parameter to 1.2
so it's 1 over I to the 1.2 then you see
that still good touring does better than
the other distribution but now you
notice that these two have changed so
here here are empirical does worse and
the plasters better and here there
have they got change but good touring
does consistently better than the other
estimators so that's for experiment in
order to get the mathematical intuition
of course needed a few definitions not
so bad so we have a distribution of a
support set X so it's x 1 up to x k k is
the number of elements and then we have
a distribution over the set which is not
known to us of course p 1 p x 1 up to PX
k and we have independent samples x1 and
independent samples such that each one
is distributed according to pee so the
probability that X I the IFTTT x CX is
just be X independently okay and of
course the main parameter that we are
looking at is the number of time that
each element appeared call it TX it's a
number of times that it appeared okay
and empirical would give a probability
which is just TX the number of times X
appeared normalized by n Laplace would
give TX plus 1 at one and then you add
one to each of them so divided by n plus
K okay so these are the definition the
basic definition for good touring we
need a few more definitions call you
need to look at how many we need to look
at how many and how many elements
appeared the same number of time and so
on so i need a few more definitions so
the number of symbols that appear t
times we call it s sub T for symbols
number of symbols that appear t times
the size number of things that appear
that number of times and what the good
drink the probability that it gives you
remember from the example we get before
you take Laplace which is T plus 1
normalize and the normalization factor
we said was n and you multiply by the
number of elements it appeared once more
divided by the number of elements it
appear the same time is what you're
interested in okay now good touring
estimate will give the same probability
to all the elements that appear at the
same number of times Elliott every
element all elements they pay three
times will get the same probability
because just a function of T ok so it
also makes sense to look at the combined
probability of all elements that appear
t times so you can just some at the
probabilities of all elements the purity
times call it the combined probability
of T 12 probability of all elements at
the beauty times so the good Turing
estimate of
of this quantity of this combined
probability is just the summation of G
of X and as we said it it does not
depend on X just depends on T so the st
such elements that number of symbols
that appear t times and for each one
gives this probability ok so the total
probability that go touring gives two
elements appearing T times T plus 1 over
N times st plus 1 ok so that's what we
get there so let's just do an a simple
example suppose that our alphabet
alphabet is ABCD and we have observed
four elements ADC ABCD then what is s0
how many symbols appeared 0 times did
not appear that's exactly 1 namely be
did not appear how many symbols appeared
once two of them a and see how many
symbols appear twice just one and what
is the combined probability of elements
that appear 0 times it's just PB the
combined probabilities of probability of
elements of hit once is PA plus BC and
the combined probability of elements
appear twice is pd ok and what good
touring does is four elements that
appeared 0 times it will give power will
key which is T plus 1 which is 1 times s
T plus 1 which is a 2 divided by n which
is four so it's 2 over 4 for things that
appeared once again to over 40 k and
things that appear twice we said it's
always going to be 0 because you're
going to look at how many elements
appeared t + 1 x which is 0 ok so this
this is the good Torian estimator ok so
now this of course is a very important
estimator it's used you know like it is
used commonly for a number of
applications it has you know very
glorified history a lot of famous people
thought about it so there are a lot of
intuitive explanations for a good Nick
touring I chose to present one inch by
jellineck and Mercer and I chose this
one for a couple of reasons one is that
this estimator is actually different
from most other estimators so little bit
thinking out outside the box and the
other
one is because this estimator may
explain while we are here this
explanation okay so everyone knows that
this host this talk is hosted by the
assignments institute okay and the
summer since these two rules created
thanks to the immense generosity of
James Simon's who was a mathematician
who then went on to become an hedge fund
manager created one of the most
successful hedge funds the trades based
on predictions of stock movements and he
retired a few years ago a couple years
ago and if you look at who runs the who
runs this fun now and used to workers
worked there for a long time it's
actually our Bob Mercer okay so here it
is like in another charity event it's in
a rare photo I guess and he took over as
co-ceo and James Simon's retired and he
comes originally from the IBM speech a
speech recognition group where they try
to recognize speech and of course what
they need to do is they need to estimate
probability affords a public of things
that have been seen a few times and in
fact a lot of the people from that group
went to Renaissance because of that
because we're trying they were working
on estimating things that have small
probability this this this this fund has
you know like manages 25 billion dollars
if you want to put a number on good
touring estimator as a good there's a
you know a number of you to start like
25 it's not 159 million million million
by still a large number okay so this is
Mercer and jellineck is Fred jellineck
was actually a very famous information
theorist and they both work together the
speech recognition group at IBM there's
a quote here that you can read but I
think we don't have much time so
occupied so ok so what is the what is
the jellineck Mercer estimator so what
they said is this suppose so we're given
n samples and based on those and samples
we want to estimate the probability of
the actual probability of an element but
let's play a thought externa thought
experiment and let's say that we we
would
in additional samples okay more samples
besides the end so so if you look at the
n plus first sample for example the next
sample what is the probability that it
will appear T times in the original
sample so I took a sample of size n I'm
trying to estimate the probability of
things that all probability of things
that appear t times and now asking you
and that that probability is is what we
call CT the combined probability of
things that appear t times I'm asking a
simple question what is the probability
that the next element will be one of
those things that appear T times it's
exactly this combined probability by
definition all right if you have if a
and B appeared twice and together the
combined probability is c2 then the
probability that the next element will
be a one of those is exactly this
combined probability c2 so so the
tautology right if city so what we can
do if you want to estimate is you take
additional samples maybe you take some n
prime of those and you try to estimate
what is the probability of this event
that that the element that you see
appeared t times in the original sample
so you just look at a fraction of those
new samples in which this happened the
fraction for which this element that you
see a PT time in the original sample if
you want to write it a little more
formal if you'll help us in the next
slide then let the indicator function of
L be one if the elf symbol appeared t
times in in this sample so you have
element number L did it appear at a time
in the samples so what is what is the
the combined probability it's this
fraction which is the summation of all
the elements in n prime elements of one
if they appeared t times in the original
sample and then you normalize by n prime
ok so this is the estimate right just
look at the fraction that appear t times
ok but the problem is that in reality we
don't have additional samples so we
don't have any more because we just have
the n samples so what we can do is we
can try to reuse the existing n samples
how do we reuse things so clearly what
we can do is we can hold out some
information look at the rest clock cross
validate and so on so we partitioned the
end samples into n minus 1 training
samples and one held out and eventually
will rotate over all of them and and and
one thing to notice is that the combined
probability of elements their purity
times in the in in the N minus 1 element
is still going to be roughly CT because
we're looking we have any is fairly
large we're thinking we took a thousand
samples you ask what is combined
probably of things that appear twice in
a thousand samples column probably going
to be very close to enough number of
elements they've told probability
elements with twice in the night in 999
samples are almost the same so the
combined probability elements appear tee
tee times n minus y is roughly city so
we can try to estimate that so 4 is
repeat using all possible and sets and
held out then what will get is the
following so we define the indicator
find the indicator function prime to be
one if the elf symbol appeared t times
in the remaining not in the original one
but in the remain it's very close to
what we had before the remaining n minus
one sample and the jellineck mercer
estimate is just do what we have done
before but just with this instead of
doing instead of doing it with the
indicated the actual indicator will do
it for it with for the N minus one set
of symbols so we are with just sum over
all elements we see if take an element
put it out and then see if in the
remaining elements it appeared T times
ok so when you look at this sum then
which symbols will contribute to the sum
a similar will contribute to the Sun if
if when you take it out it appear T
times so maybe this element appeared T
plus 1 times ok so it appeared r T plus
1 times and then how much will it
contribute it will how many such
elements now the st plus one right
because that's the number of elements
that appear t plus 1 times ok clear so
therefore what we get is that you that
you have T plus 1 times s T plus 1
divided by N and that's the jellineck
Mercer estimate and that's exactly the
good touring estimate ok right ok so
what you see is if we do this
calculation you also get good touring
it's exactly the same ok so that's but
of course it's an intuitive explanation
it's not a proof because
a couple of things first of all how do
we know that CT is roughly the same as
CT minus C editor with N and n minus 1
and and and the download dependencies
come up and so on all right okay so in
terms of actual proofs they started
appearing in two thousand and a lot of
credit should go to David McAllister and
rupture period and what they showed was
that with high probability in probably
close to one you can estimate you you
can estimate city is the total
probability of things that appear T
times and this is the good torrent you
can estimate to a fraction of 1 over
square root of n okay T plus 1 over
square root of n sewed and this holds
for all distribution so this this result
holds regardless of our alphabet size
okay so so this result so in other words
it doesn't matter how large the alphabet
size is you can if you have n samples
then you can estimate you can estimate c
t to t plus 1 over square root of n so
of course this is good only 40 which is
less than square root of N and so drew
can win sir extended this by using a
Pyrrhic of frequency for large element
and they got that you can estimate every
element within 1 over N to the 0.4 okay
so we have been taking a more
information theoretic approach to this
and derive some results and one thing
that has helped us is that we have been
using so so we've done we've looked at
two aspects of this problem one is in a
prediction setting and this is a result
from about 10 years ago with with June
and Jang and passat santhanam graduating
here and the second approach which is
more like what I am going to explain in
the next how many minutes how much time
do I have 10 minutes perfect okay thank
you so and that's that's a more recent
resolve this this paper is from a year
and a half ago in cult and
that by godiva char is now postdoc at
MIT and ashkan Jeff oh boy is here and
Toyota or I mentioned earlier okay so
what has helped us a lot is looking at
pass on sampling and I know that a lot
of you are familiar with this technique
what it does but for some sampling does
is it lets you eliminate dependencies
and also simplify a lot of the
calculations and in this case it's
almost like person was almost built for
good wearing estimation and that I think
has helped us go beyond what people have
done before because a lot of things
become very very clean as you'll see
within 10 minutes second i think i can
show so so first of all I want to use
this Poisson approximation to give you
some intuition as to what happens when
you have a uniform distribution so in
general the distribution fee can be
anything and we want to approximate it
but of course it's easier for some
distributions than others so let's see
what good touring does for uniform
distribution okay and I think you'll be
very clear so so we take uniform
distribution of the key elements and
think of case being large okay and then
we take n samples but because we're
doing the Poisson sampling we're taking
persona and sample so we're taking a
number that is close to end but this
Poisson distributed okay and then if you
do that then you can see you know I skip
that slide but but you can see that the
number of times that a symbol X will
appear will go is going to be porcelain
over K so it's not just the whole number
of samples porcelain but each symbol is
distributed person with n over K because
that's the expectation so we call lambda
n over K we call it lambda so each each
each symbol will appear Poisson lambda
our number of times and lambda is n over
K so what is the probability that a
symbol will appear T times it's the co2
Poisson lambda so it's e to the lambda e
minus lambda lambda to the T over T
factorial that's that's the probability
that a single X will appear at T times
ok so now how many symbols will appear T
times it's what we called st the normal
filled symbols of the purity times its
symbols appears appears RT times this
for
will be publicly let it steep this this
probability and that K of them so you
expect the number of symbols that will
appear t times to be K times this
probability and four symbols that appear
t times what is the good touring
estimate to remember it was Laplace T
plus 1 and then multiplied by the ratio
of number of elements appear once more
divide the number of elements that we
are the same amount of time and we said
the normalization factor was n okay so
what is it it's T plus 1 over N now what
is st plus 1 how many elements will
appear t plus 1 times it's just lambda 2
it's just this formula it's just this
formula okay so so first of all k will
cancel so you get the probability
divided by the probability and e to the
minus lambda will also cancel so you're
left with lambda to the T plus 1 divided
by T personal favor factorial divided by
lambda to the T over T factorial when
you look at it I've got to get a lot of
cancellations so here you get lambda
which is n over K so you get n over K
and he'll get one over T plus 1 which is
1 over K in other words we started with
a uniform distribution every element has
probability 1 over K we took a sample
samples are all over the place some of
them appeared n over K times some of
them appeared any other times but for
each any symbol go touring will give
probably 1 over K period so somehow it
figured out exactly what was under
sampled what was over sampled and so on
and it puts everything it puts it back
so what happened was you started with a
delta function everything is one okay
when you took the when you took the
sample behaves more like AG out for a
solenoid Gaussian okay but by looking at
the ratio it multiplies by remember what
we the example get by there a show this
is the ratio right here it actually
multiplies the back to move it moves it
back to uniform so I think we need when
you see this you understand good touring
how simple it actually is okay so that's
this was assuming that um that we
started with a uniform distribution but
of course in reality if we knew that we
was a uniform distribution we would not
need to do anything so you want you care
what happens for general distributions
so let me show you an equally simple
proof
that good touring is unbiased so
remember the combined probability city
is the combined probability of all
things that appeared three times so we
can write it as summation of indicator
functions so its summation of p x times
the probability that x appear two times
that's the combined probability of
things that appeared t times it's a
random variable good touring estimate is
GT is dat plus 1 over N times st plus 1
we said it several times by now so it's
t plus 1 over N but what is st plus 1
it's again a sum of indicated function
its summation of all X of the indicating
function that X appeared t plus 1 times
so we see that we have a very similar
expression for CT the combined
probabilities for GT is just different
sums of of indicator functions it's just
different coefficients okay so let's
look at the expected value of GT okay
the expected value of GT is therefore
just looking at this formula here just
looking this phone is summation over X
of T plus 1 over n times the expected
value of this symbol of the indicator
function I'm sorry okay so what is the
expected values is an indicator function
it's a zero one run over ball it's
Bernoulli so the expected values
probability that it's one it's a
probability that X appeared t plus 1
times trivially the probability that X
appeared he taught us one x la if you
let n PX b lambda x that's the expected
number of time so it's lambda x to the T
plus 1 divided by T plus 1 factorial I
should have had so I should have had
four entrances okay and and so this so
when you look at this it'll sort of begs
you to to to to cancel the T plus 1
right and be left with defect or it also
begs you once you sit effectual begs you
to to take the one out to put the lambda
X here ok so what you get is summation
of lambda x over n e to the minus lambda
times lambda X to the T divided by
factorial what is this this is clearly
the indicator to function the same the
probability that are this is the
probability that X appear t times which
is the expected value of the indicator
function same same logic right so what
you have is that its summation and now
lambda x over N
just pee so its summation p x times the
expected times the expected value of the
indicator function which according to
this is just the expected value of the
combined probability so this is like
outside under graduate early
undergraduate calculation shows you that
how wide the guttering is an unbiased
estimator okay and once you notice it's
an unbiased estimator you're almost all
the way there because all you need to
show is that each when you look at CT
which is the quantity of trying to
estimate ngt which is your estimated we
just need to show that they're actually
close to the to the expected value
because if both of them they have the
same expected value both of them are
close to that expectation value then
you're done okay but each of them is
very conveniently as sum of independent
random variables because we are doing
porous on so the number of times that X
appears is independent of the number of
times that X prime appears so each of
them is the sum of independent random
variables so everything works nicely and
you can calculate the variance almost
essentially it's easy i would say and
you see that it has zero bias and
moderate variance and that's why you you
can get it done okay so now the new
result that so this is just may be a
simple proof of the good touring
estimator and so on then what people
have done before but you can once you
have such a simple explanation then you
can get new result and don't have much
time but basically what they do is so
you observe that the good touring
estimated the original go to an
estimated zero bias and moderate via
parents so a natural thing to ask is
whether you can modify it so that maybe
you will have a little bit of a bias but
smaller variance okay and the good
touring estimate just looks at the
number of things that appeared t x
number of things i paired t plus 1 times
but it it's not there's nothing magical
about t plus 1 is supposed to t minus
one so you can maybe look at t plus 1 t
plus 2t plus 3 you average them so the
various will be smaller but now we
introduce some bias okay so that's what
this estimator does and when you do it
you can show that if you try to estimate
so you have a distribution it's actually
interesting you don't see it from these
results but you have a distribution over
any number of elements could be like
trilling k the alphabet size doesn't
matter
and you have some fixed number of
samples n and you can estimate the
distribution at an accuracy which is
independent of the alphabet size so if
you look at l1 distance of two distances
people care about typically one of them
is the l1 distance the other one is the
KL divergence if you look at say l1
distance then you get to 1 over n to the
1 over quarter this is the accuracy that
you get the alphabet size does not even
matter if you use good time okay and
there's the also matching lower bound so
this these are the right orders okay and
does not depend on okay let me just talk
about application i'll try finish in
three minutes okay so they i promised
you in the abstract talking about
applications i want to tell you about
one that we like which is for
classification so what is classification
you have two distributions that are
known p and q and you get to training
set one from p and one from q so you get
some samples from p and some samples
from q and then a new sample comes in
and you want to decide as it come from p
or does it come from q okay so here are
some examples so let's assume that p and
Q are equal likely it's probably half
you choose the distribution P probably
half you choose the distribution Q so
let's assume that the training from p.r
aab in the training from QR BCB now if
you get a as the classification as the
I'm sorry the test so now it comes in
which one would you say it comes from
probably most people say comes from this
distribution because appear twice here
if you get be probably would say Council
this distribution if you take see also
comes from this distribution if you get
deed then maybe you don't know and and
and and you just say I don't know okay
so what are applications for this you
know clearly spam filter and get example
spam emails and good emails your
examples of movies you like in movies
you don't like and then a new then I
knew it comes in and Netflix tries to
decide if you're going to like it or not
and so on or you have samples your
physician you have samples of sick
patients and people just think that are
sick and new person comes in and you
want to decide and so so in other words
of we you can imagine everything in life
like that and so a very natural
assumption is once you look at it is
it's very clear what we should do right
now we should classify take the element
that we that we're trying to classify
see if it appeared more times in the in
the P sample or more time in the queue
sample and just classify accordingly
correct so i have a new sample let's say
it's the letter C I see how many times
it appears sick patients had this
condition how many times healthy patient
had this symptom and then I sign it to
the one with the most weight appeared
the most correct very obvious very wrong
it's not the best thing to do so the
best thing to do is as you can guess is
to use the good during estimate
estimation to estimate the probability
of the symbol and go touring will change
things and will not just look at the
number of times everything appear every
symbol appeared but look at number of
times things appeared once more and so
on and once you do that things get them
and get mixed up and if you do empirical
frequency if you just look at the counts
the individual accounts you will not get
result that is uniformly optimal but if
you do good torrent you get a result
it's uniformly optimal in what sense if
you have to distribution P and Q then um
then there is some best there is the
best classification error that you could
get if you knew the two distributions
okay and what your goal is to is to get
this to this error and what you can do
is if you do good touring then you get
to this best error that one anyone at
percent anuta to distribution we get
plus 1 over n to the 1 5th plus an hour
that goes down with the with the number
of samples but is independent of the
alphabet size so get a uniform
convergence no matter how big they
offered it sizes and I should mention
that this is this is for our classifiers
that are labeled invariant so so
classifier that actually all natural
classifiers are like that if I'm going
to reliable things then should behave
the same way
and runs in a time and so on okay so let
me just say some experience so here is
an experiment so we have to zip
distribution one is parameter one with
parameter 1.5 if you try to classify
you're using the empirical classified
the common sense classified it just
looks how were things appeared more then
your error is a function of the number
of training samples we go down like the
red line if you use the empirical
frequency I'm sorry fuse I'm sorry good
touring so I it was a good touring
estimator will go like that so if we
look for example for 60 samples small
number it's not like we need to go to a
very large number it goes from 40
whatever 42 and a half percent to like
thirty nine percent so it's a reasonable
decrease like ten percent or something
like that and that's where you get here
here so what's the conclusion of all
this so clearly we can stop here because
we know how to predict what's going to
happen so thank you
yeah yeah there's a crush on the back so
all these estimators are there are
combination of you want to use good
touring only four elements that appeared
very few times if you want to estimate
to use good touring for an element let's
say took a thousand samples and just you
try to estimate the public of something
that appeared 500 times cannot use good
touring because the probability will
give it will be 0 because there'll be
nothing else that appeared 500 in one
times so all these things are have they
take combination of different estimators
for different ranges of the number of
times the things that have appeared and
what you do is you try to balance the
error of the good touring estimator and
the air of empirical frequency we can
see what these arrows will start coming
in because you have standard deviations
that will have things like square root
of N and you try to balance them and
together when you put them together you
get these quantities
no that is absolutely tired let me just
answer the easier thing or the thing
that more calm or happy to answer the
seen and unseen is is an artifact let's
not dwell on this it's just the unseen
is just a special case of something
that's it been once twice three times in
this case zero times so I'm not too
worried about unseen is just like a nice
word for things that are named for
things appear do times but you're right
that this is a very idealized case of
classification you don't have features
you just have elements and they've been
seen twice or three times or four sayang
times and now they come and you try to
to classify or so you try to estimate
the distribution so I agree this is a
very basic this is maybe the most basic
question about calcification but if you
want to apply to actual real-world
problems then you have to deal with
other things it's a good question
whether this this intuition and and this
algorithms can be then applied to more
complex structures it's definitely
question good question